turkey has blocked talks on Finland and
Sweden joining NATO both Nordic Nations
have formally submitted membership bids
new members need unanimous agreement
from the 30 current States but turkey is
standing firmly against Turkish
president
accuses Finland and Sweden of harboring
Kurdish terrorists another dispute is
over sophisticated weaponry
for turkey the issue could actually be
about U.S fighter jets
turkey was dropped from the F-35
advanced fighter jet development program
in 2019
this was part of a U.S sanctions packet
imposed on the country after it bought a
Russian air defense system
many believe anchor is now hoping to
pressure the U.S into selling it new
F-16 fighter jets instead an extremely
controversial Topic in Washington
another issue in 2019 Sweden halted
weapons deliveries to Turkey after it
attacked Kurdish people's defense units
in Northern Syria and launched an
offensive there
kind of Museum
Turkish president reject type erdogan
could consider this grounds enough to
block the start of NATO accession talks
for Sweden and Finland possibly
destabilizing the alliance in the
process
it would play into President Putin's
hands it would send a signal that
there's no Unity within NATO the wrong
signal at precisely the wrong moment
in New York U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken and his Turkish
counterpart mevlut Chapel met in an
attempt to find a compromise their Shabu
Shola made turkey's position clear has
been supporting the open door policy of
NATO even before this war but with
regards to this possible candidates or
already candidate countries you know we
have also a legitimate security concerns
that they have been supporting terrorist
organizations and there are also export
restrictions on defense products every
concession turkey wins from the
situation will likely isolate it further
in NATO circles but will win president
erdogan political points at home
something he will welcome as turkey
heads towards presidential elections
next year
let's go more than on that meeting
between the turkisha foreign minister
and the U.S Secretary of State at Innis
poll is our Washington bureau chief
welcome innus how did the meeting go
Finland and Sweden signaled they were
thinking of making the historic decision
joining NATO the alliance expected a
tough response from Moscow not from one
of its own so ever since turkey raised
conditions for accepting the membership
the rest of NATO was actually really
irritated and pretty outspoken about it
however we hear from today's meeting
between the foreign minister of turkey
and Biden's National Security adviser
blinking that both sides are on a path
to find an agreement but at this point
they don't mention this is the the
specifics right so what's in it what's
what does turkey want out of this
meeting then
right so Anchor's main demands are for
the Nordic countries to hold support for
Kurdish militant uh groups present on
there on the Nordic territory and they
also uh want them to live their bands on
some sales of arms to Turkey add-ons is
obviously using the current war in
Ukraine to raise his case as he knows
how important it is for NATO to stay
United against Vladimir Putin plus
erdogan is also facing an election with
in his own country and his paws are
really down so he definitely wants to
show strength to his own people yeah and
this is not his first argument with NATO
allies so uh clearly he's not bothered
about his country being isolated within
the alliance
uh well I wouldn't go so far but uh I
think it is fair to say that he is often
playing kind of both sides what do I
mean with that for example he fights
with Russia in Syria uh on the one hand
but supports Ukraine against Putin's
Army so why does he do that because he
wants to be seen as kind of an
indispensable mediator which allows him
after all to keep doing business with
everyone he wants to
so do we think then is the thinking that
turkey will really stop Sweden and
Finland from joining NATO or will a deal
be done
it's a very confident that they will
reach a settlement
and there seems actually I mean from my
understanding being here in Washington
and Reporting about the White House
there seems no way that NATO really
would give erdogan this power and I
think it is pretty possible that we know
more after Biden met with the presidents
of Sweden and Finland tomorrow here in
Washington at the White House think of
that innocenter's poll in Washington